this is you made from ordinary atoms and
molecules and this is you if you were
made out of dark matter that's how it
works right
no what would it be like if every
particle in your body converted into a
dark matter particle and how long could
you last in that state this is what if
and here's what would happen if you were
made of dark matter everything that we
can see in the universe is a massive
mashup of electrons protons and neutrons
fused into atoms it's what's called
baryonic or just ordinary matter your
body is made up of it too but there is a
lot of stuff out there that we don't see
stuff that we call dark matter and dark
energy if you were to undergo a dark
matter transformation your existence as
you know it would come to an end
instantly but as compensation you'd get
the ability to move through virtually
anything you want before we change your
body composition let's make some things
clear there's no concrete proof that
Dark Matter exists and we currently have
no technology available to find that
proof so how can we know about dark
matter in the first place well if you
run some cosmic calculations based on
physics as we know it it turns out that
the amount of visible material in the
universe doesn't add up here's an
example a spiral galaxy like the one we
live in has stars and its outer edges
according to what physics says these
stars should be moving at a much slower
pace compared to the ones close to the
galactic center but in reality all stars
in the galaxy seem to be orbiting its
center point and almost the same speed
scientists think that that's dark matter
influencing the effects of gravity and
making the Stars move the way they do
Dark Matter doesn't interact with
ordinary matter at all it's invisible to
electromagnetic radiation and light the
only thing that makes scientists think
Dark Matter exists is its gravitational
effects on galaxies scientists also
think that dark matter outweighs visible
matter by approximately six to one
making up 27 percent of the universe now
let's get back to your dark matter
transformation if you're of an average
weight of say 70 kilograms your body has
about 7 billion billion billion atoms in
it your atoms form molecules molecules
form cells and cells form vitals that
you can see with your eyes like your
organs if all of your ordinary matter
atoms switched to dark matter atoms your
physical body would disintegrate without
ordinary matter there would be nothing
to glue your atoms together anymore but
this wouldn't be the end of your story
you'd become invisible and your body
wouldn't appear as a collective whole
but your dark matter particles would
still interact gravitationally trapped
by Earth's gravity those particles would
start an endless marathon around the
center of Earth's gravity the core
they'd be circling in an elliptical
orbit at the speed of 3 kilometers per
second
every 88 minutes your dark matter would
make a whole circle back to the place of
your transformation the dark matter
particles that used to be you would
slowly drift over time on your first
Dark Matter birthday your particles
would show up about a 1/2 meter from the
spot where they were born after 10 years
that distance would be half a kilometer
that's because dark matter you wouldn't
be influenced by our planets rotation
dark matter is only affected by gravity
there would be no energy or momentum
loss you would never reform to become an
ordinary matter you again you would just
keep circling around the Earth's core
of course nothing can turn you into a
Dark Matter entity in real life but that
doesn't mean that there's no dark matter
around you the mathematics behind it can
get somewhat complex but scientists have
estimated that the average person has 10
to the power of negative 22 kilograms of
dark matter in their body at any given
time throughout your life approximately
one milligram of dark matter will pass
directly through you so while
technically you can never be entirely
made up of dark matter it's incredible
to think about how something we don't
know much about could be so close to us
even part of us there is so much to
learn about the universe and how it
behaves maybe we would have a better
grasp of it if the earth had been born
somewhere inside a globular cluster and
not on the outskirts of the Milky Way
galaxy well that's a story for another
what if
you